have you noticed though that like what
you wear in the uk is completely
different to what you would normally
wear here like in terms of like sense of
fashion because i feel like at least
with me like sometimes i
wouldn't dress like this in australia
for instance uh why i don't know because
i feel that like just in general just i
don't know maybe it's just the area that
i live in but like japan i feel has
definitely like put in like a different
sense of fashioning to me than back in
australia like it to me in australia
fashion was t-shirt shorts sandals yeah
i mean that's australia right yeah i
mean that that was like that's that was
like that was like isn't it the national
motto yeah it's like it's like you you'd
feel fancy if you wore a pair of jeans
you know like it's like that little
right but here it's like i don't know i
i feel weird going out with t-shirt
shorts and sandals i mean i think i
think it's just living in a country
that's permanently in summer right
because because like that's kind of me
in thailand where if i'm not wearing
t-shirts shorts and sandals something
special is happening like so it's like
this like in in england you look for any
opportunity you can to wear shorts in
thailand you look for any opportunity
you can to wear jeans and long sleeves i
want to wear jeans i don't really like
wearing shorts yeah i i don't really
feel comfortable in them why i don't
know i just i don't know like exposing
your life maybe i haven't found the
right pair yes you know when you sit on
i feel like i'm like how short of shorts
are you wearing though no i have
reasonably sized
i feel like i can't enjoy every service
you know when you sit down on some
things you're wearing shorts like oh god
i don't like all my skin touches this
jeez
what about like three quarter pants
oh there's a bit strange on there yeah
see like it's weird like something like
three quarter pants is completely normal
here but i would feel super [ __ ]
weird if i wore three quarter pants in
australia and it's not because of like
the weather it's just because like i
wouldn't see anyone in australia just
fashion wise wearing three quarter pants
i i just i just don't think shorts look
very good like like they no no no no
okay so so one looks good in short no
look it's
like
every australian is offended
no one looks better in shorts than they
would wearing like
jeans okay yeah okay because like it's
it's sunny outside okay so people can
look good on the beach or whatever in
shorts or whatever
any time you go inside you sit down on
the restaurant you look like a [ __ ]
clown there is no exception to not
looking like a clown when you go inside
and you're and you're wearing shorts
like they're like i'm watching like the
trash taste off the dark screen and i'm
just like [ __ ] hell our legs look so
ugly like
knees on knees underneath yeah there's
just there's just so many knees man like
too much skin going on and if it's just
like the three quarter pants well you
just
like at that point you just have
commitment issues just commit to shorts
or commit to jeans like like please come
on that's just
like yeah i think being
being uh from the uk i feel like fashion
was never a high priority well yeah and
i feel and i feel in the same way with
australia as well like i feel just i
never even thought about what i was
wearing in australia because i look
around me and i'm like i don't really
see anyone who's like fashionable people
are so much [ __ ] drip here it's
insane yeah
people will like be going to work and
they'll be dressed like a [ __ ] model
and that's and i feel that's why i
almost not so much pressured but i guess
like i kind of that made me look at
myself i feel like
bro i mean i i feel like london was
pretty fashionable london oh everyone
dressed the same i feel really everyone
everyone dresses the same i feel in
london i feel like like i i would say
that even maybe people in london have
even more drip than people here in tokyo
i i that's that's my genuine opinion you
see so much like you see
[Music]
why can we not agree over [ __ ] london
you like you like the architecture
[ __ ] hater i i think you look right i
think london's a fashionable city if you
look at like uh [ __ ] primark or
anything the models everyone [ __ ]
dress what the [ __ ] you talking about
primark slaps like four four four the
for what you get for the price the
primark fashion [ __ ] amazing [ __ ]
child labor you can get some good
clothes you know that's right probably
promoting remember one time i bought ten
t-shirts for eight pounds in primark and
i thought [ __ ] hell who made a deal
with the devil here why was this price
able to go through i bought i bought one
thing at primark and it was a pair of
eight sonic the hedgehog socks
for five pounds that's way that's
overpriced what the [ __ ] five pounds you
got mugged off they're like one pounds
for each stuff yeah but i'm like i
bought a whole suit from primark for
like 30 quid and i'm like
what the [ __ ] what happened and it
looked it looked decent right it looked
decent that's the problem it looked good
what do you mean that's the problem i i
i think now i'm like you know we we paid
what like [ __ ] 70 pounds for a
t-shirt no 70 dollars for t-shirts i
want 40 pounds for a t-shirt i now feel
that you know maybe it's because i have
more money now
maybe it's because i'm not i'm doing
much better for myself i feel that i
think i would rather pay 30 40 for a
very good t-shirt as opposed to eight
dollars for ten t-shirts yeah yeah but
like that's that's that's the thing the
biggest thing i've i've noticed
something's gone wrong i i feel like the
biggest difference since moving to japan
is that there were just more affordable
options in high street and in high
streets in the uk but how much how much
affordable is like
we're cutting some severe human rights
corners here well i'm no this is this is
like i mean that's that's going to a
different topic we're talking about drip
right and people having drip i feel like
especially in london a lot of people
have the drip comes with a costco
of course it comes with the board
but like you you look here and basically
like if it's just uniqlo here and uniqlo
and like a few other places here but in
in england you just have a lot of
choices and there is like no equivalent
to primark i think worldwide there's
been nowhere in the world i've gone to
that is a really really cheap place to
find clothes and just looks as good as
primark i'm just i'm i'm i don't know i
think i will happily still shop at
primark now i think i think primark
clothes are like underrated just because
it's cheap but you look at primark
clothes and you could easily sell that
for like i just always walk out with
like five t-shirts i'm never gonna wear
because i thought they looked good in
the store
because it's so cheap because you're
like i'll have five and that's literally
me at unicorn it's it's it's literally
like the primark is the equivalent of
going to an all-you-can-eat buffet at a
restaurant right you're just like maybe
i feel like having an indian curry and a
pizza at the same time
but it's just just like you do it
because just like well i just got so
much choice i just maybe i'll have a bit
of mexican as well and a bit of chinese
and he just and it's just an absolute
[ __ ] mess or flight response is
kicking and tearing and then you [ __ ]
yourself and violently and then you wipe
it away with magic you know
i'll i'll i'll oh i'll look fine bring
it back you can have it yeah sure drip
yeah
wait so are you saying prime mark is
drip i'm not saying you're saying pro
mark is dripping okay i said to make
sure i'm saying primark is affordable
drip it it doesn't it doesn't look
that's an oxymoron
why why i don't know like
what is drip
expensive clothes just drip is like i
thought it was just closed that looked
good yeah but it's kind of like the
hypebeast stuff as well yeah there's
really expensive oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
drift that just means that good drip you
know you have to buy brand's name [ __ ]
for good kind of usually that's you yeah
that's
kind of been it's kind of been developed
a bit more now and kind of hijacked to
be more of just good clothes yeah just
fashionable clothing just fashionable
clothing that's what i that's what when
i heard drip i that's what i always
thought it was you know sometimes brand
name clothes
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's what someone who
doesn't wear dreams yeah
are you telling me that every brand name
stuff looks good there are equally as
many brand name stuff that i'm just like
this looks like absolute dog turd and if
i see if i see someone wearing that i'm
gonna think they have zero drip you can
wear a louie that could be louis vuitton
and
i get that but like at the same time you
know if i was like walking down the
street floating off my drip right and
then someone came up to me and was like
damn that drip sick where'd you get that
i wouldn't like be like
primark like yeah i'm not i'm not gonna
[ __ ] say that
i'll [ __ ] say that if it looks good
who the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] if it looks
like if you look like you have drip then
you have drip i can't i couldn't matter
where it comes from doesn't matter like
doesn't [ __ ]
is like the biggest the biggest [ __ ]
scam there is are you saying to me i
don't know i just wanna i just want
something i don't feel bad about buying
now i just want something that lasts as
well i'm obviously not gonna like you
know [ __ ] go to every high-end place
and buy like a you know 500 old t-shirts
so many t-shirts from primark that i
sweat in once and it is like permanently
stained i cannot get those orange pits
out to save my life yeah i mean that's
why you buy five of them right well
that's the problem is that i feel bad
about buying a shirt that i've been
immediately yeah after i have one bad
summer
i mean i mean the the fabric is like
definitely low problems
i don't want to buy a shirt that i feel
like i can only get two or three good
wears out of exactly well that that's
what you pay for when you pay for cheap
fabrics but that's what i'm saying like
why don't you use that money to just buy
one good quality one i'm lost and it's
more
[ __ ] those little kids making those
shirts you got drip
i mean an affordable price i mean you've
just been brainwashed by the fashion
industry to say this looks good because
it's expensive it has a brand's name i
always think that you pay for the
quality material that lasts a while yeah
i agree
the quality material doesn't always
equate
we buy those glam shirts right they're
like they're like 60 bucks a t-shirt
sometimes like you've got some serious
mileage out there yeah so i i'm not i
like it gladly if people that shit's
drippy yeah dude if people are like bro
oh it's sixty dollars a t-shirt bro how
many of those t-shirts have you bought
from like primark and [ __ ] that like
that are [ __ ] garbage you have to
like i'm i'm not arguing that but i'm
arguing that you can buy good quality
good-looking stuff for a lot cheaper
than you can get for glam and everything
like that i just think fast fashion is
like bad for the environment it's just
bad in general i just think you should
buy shirts that just buy something that
lasts spicy are you saying that
i mean you saying that a t-shirt should
always be like 30 dollars minimum 30-50
it's not so much about the price for me
it's about like what it's made of right
and like
t-shirts that i don't wear because i
just have too many t-shirts because a
lot of them i would just buy
because they were cheap yeah i would
never end up wearing them i would always
wear the nicer shirts that i could clean
didn't didn't you also say that you just
you don't wash jeans you just throw them
away and bite
i would wear a pair of jeans for like
two years until they are [ __ ] i would
buy the same pair of jeans over and over
again well you don't wash your jeans i
would i would rarely wash them
you don't need to wash jesus why are we
talking about drip again
you don't need you're taking drip advice
from you this is going to wash your
teeth you're taking dripping
from a guy who doesn't wash his jeans
i'm i'm sorry who is the peasant here
connor i'm sorry who is the [ __ ]
peasant here look look i will argue
right that yes like you could buy a 10
shirt right from primark or something
and you can you know you can layer with
something you know off cheap and you can
make it look good yeah well what i'm
saying is the average
you should never wash a pair of jeans is
one of the ceo of a gene company says
the ceo of a gene continually if it's a
good quality said michael jeans
if it's a good quality gene you don't
need to wash it
i will spot wash that [ __ ] you got a
stain just get rid of the stain
i i i do not know enough about this
topic should you get it genuinely you
don't need a water
get that [ __ ] out of my face they smell
fresh that's that musky [ __ ] no i've
been sweating in these they smell good
that is drip that's dripping with your
[ __ ] sweater connor is that what
you're talking about what do you mean
drip there's some stains here and then i
just got a spot cleaner god you don't
know how many people would pay for that
experience
small connor's jeans
get the [ __ ] out of my face man all
these jeans smell it smells good yeah
yeah man give him a wife
i just would you say that after wearing
it in the summer i don't like washing my
jeans because
and frankly as well i don't like how
they feel after you do wash them they
feel horrible the first time you wear
them after you wash jeans they feel all
like crinkly and you've got to wear them
back in again i don't like that well i
mean that's if you do like a cold wash
though no no warm water if you do a warm
wash where it doesn't like shrink then
it's fine oh it still does it really oh
you're buying the cheap jeans now i'm
just no no i'm not
it's uniqlo's finest
[Music]
i mean to be fair unicorn does do good
jeans i'm just saying you don't you
don't wash jeans
i mean
i i just i wear the same pair of jeans
like i don't have multiple i only have
one pair of jeans when it breaks i just
buy a new one when it gets holes buy a
new one when the stains are too deep i
get a new one that's pretty much all i
do if you're considered like you know
like removing the color from like you
know from your shirt i want my jeans to
look fresh
just soft wash everything yeah
you don't need to wash jeans
well there you go i mean the drip king
has spoken
you don't need to wash jeans apparently
i mean i just i just think i just think
i just think fashion is [ __ ] don't
worry about how much you spend i mean
it's glad to know that you have trash
taste gone i mean i mean like okay like
i the one thing i never got for example
was supreme right like okay
that's a different caliber that's what
you mean that's a different character
because that's what comes out it all
comes off right no no like supreme how
is it literally a brand's name
that's expensive as [ __ ] no that's no
that's not a brand it's that's a meme
yeah that's a man yeah supreme is
amazing
they made a crowbar no one is going
around being like this they made a brick
yeah this is not this is not a company
that is is in the business of making
extremely high quality stuff it's in the
business of making scarce stuff
it is a meme but it wasn't always a meme
if you go you go to any asian country
back when it was like in their prime and
people had supreme on just because it
was expensive and it was one of the
biggest brand names it wasn't like good
quality
that was it wasn't good supreme was
escape right supreme isn't like a daily
wear like skateboarders used to wear
that that was like made for
skateboarding yeah but for the longest
time that was drip that was drip right
no you can't you can't argue with me you
gotta go there hasn't been a single like
you might have seen there hasn't been a
single piece of supreme
shirts or anything
like that philly the old definition of
drip was brand was brand new yeah it was
like gucci louis vuitton all that kind
of stuff right but i feel like now
because it's been adopted so much and
used so much over the past few months it
does just mean looking good yeah and i'm
just saying you don't need to [ __ ]
buy expensive stuff or brands no you
don't you have a drip you also shouldn't
be buying 10 t-shirts for five years
you also shouldn't you also shouldn't be
wearing a primark shirt and calling it
drip yeah
i i think you can call it drip i'm just
saying if if if you lay everything right
if you if you layer it right if you
layer right but there isn't a single
person going to primark and being like
time to buy some drugs
no one goes to primark thinking that so
if you spend 30 t-shirts right that i
think that's a worthwhile investment
you're wearing this [ __ ] every day yeah
you know
like if it looks good that 30 t-shirt is
going to last you longer than those
three ten pounds
yeah probably like i'm not saying don't
buy 30 t-shirts if it looks all i'm
saying is if it looks good it looks good
doesn't matter about the price doesn't
matter about the [ __ ] brand name like
like it's it's it's all a [ __ ] scam
anyway because i think at that point it
literally just comes to like that
person's personal preference of like do
they consider this drip or noise
i'm just saying just i i'm [ __ ] dumb
i think we're really [ __ ] dumb like
what what the [ __ ] does that
to my mouth this is a [ __ ] debate
like three people have no idea in
fashion being like what is drip i feel
like i'm arguing the best way to perform
open heart surgery i feel like i'm
really not qualified to be discussing
this obviously awareness not none of us
three least qualified people to talk
about triple that doesn't mean i'm not
going to ask you for it